Hey guys,
It is summer here in South Africa.
Man it is hot.
I'm just taking a quick walk outside of the
house just to connect with you guys because
our team's been working really hard these
last few months and I apologize that we
couldn't get the men's lifestyle video to
you yesterday, that we are late this week.
We tried, we couldn't get it on time so apologies
but expect some interesting things this year.
We're almost at 1 million and I just want
to thank you all for the support and just
remind you to live life fully and remember
that this is the day that the Lord has made.
I will rejoice and be glad in it.
Check out this view.
Thank you so much for all the
support over the last few years.
Please watch one of these videos here
because you might not have seen them yet.
I'll see you there and always
remember, life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.